you don't think where altering the crime
it you're not big on Climate Change
maybe a little more evidence will prove
it to you I
so there's been a major major drought
there saying what are the biggest if not
the biggest rout ever in california is
happening right now
and workers in Northern California right
now
are engaging this massive mission to
move 25
million baby salmon from five million
hatcheries
to the ocean so that they can breathe
and live lives in grow
a we've got some voters so this is
they're just moving them I mean they're
moving there's a lot of famine in those
trucks
there's a lot of may get their hands on
those trucks happy yeah that's right
we've got 10 the salmon flowing through
a pipe so then they
height they're literally piping them
into were taking them from at risk they
will die
her where they are because of the
drought and I were planning on the ocean
we've got one more
at his hand being released into the
pacific her
okay cells ceremoniously deposited
yet yeah I'm gonna break your life
watching when others
artificial insemination and everybody
got larger levelers I
very much like but hidden video then put
it in the bush in and then perspire
that's right yeah are we totally look
I'm a guy I know I'm making a bid a job
I don't have any empirical evidence that
is this is absolutely climate change I
that I roll your eyes trying to be a
little more highbrow back I am
yeah all of our environment stories I
could just at the MU arm
number I look we don't have any evidence
that this specifically is because it's
something that humans have done
to the environment we keep hearing more
and more about the stories
and species that are going extinct and
and climates that are changing and
changing topography in all this stuff
are we just gonna
just simply destroy this yr a
the earth is pretty resilient
considering meteorites have hit
like that some little little more I
we personally our phase may be done
the phase up this form a biped may be
done I think something's gonna come up
and make it the numbers the numbers may
be done that early
largeness going away we may get back a
bunch
this this whatever this is we I mean
unless they come up with some
super neato thing that can reverse all
this real quick
the scientists have a decided that yet
where we're already
on a thus the slippery slope downhill
a mars thats but mars up now but you the
whole point going there to back it up
break a whole book lol
gets gets all like it moved the iron ore
out a bit but that's the thing about
this %ah fishery thing which is
you know I guess part it was that they
can't
if they let them go their normal route
is not enough rivers and streams they're
going to take a left turn is a right
turn at some point or whatever but
anyway I P
salmon aren't these the fish that are
more earned
and then they go down there little
saying they go out the ocean they live a
life like oh hey I need to make babies
and they turn around and they go back up
the
how are they gonna do that part so but
so that a little confusing 10
go to the coastline to wait for their
truck to show I
like that yeah it'll semi truck to get
that father
hey that's actually really funny like
they get dropped over the ocean
it actually changes everything that they
make Yahoo
really concerned about this part we need
this week to a dry and a third so we're
not scientists and I know we're gonna
have some tats I did you know your
YouTube thing but if you wanna why
there's an amazing that mean I think
maybe I need to come back to life with
the salmon
if you wanna know why senator so healthy
person eat just watched a documentary
because you their whole life is going
swimming upstream and you can see how
they're building their muscles
any then becomes beverage with omega 3's
in the fatty acids that we need
so we're really screwed up some serious
but nothing too I'll it when I read the
whole article about this is that you
know the reason we're doing this
okay yeah for the salmon and everything
no not really
it so that we can have locks on the East
Coast II
for all people so you're saying the
bagel lobby
dont they get here at the Battle of the
great value your
editor and and you're depositing them
into Pacific which is now radioactive so
it's going to be a lock seller
I we talk about Fukushima a couple weeks
ago there there say Shema
yeah exactly they're saying that its net
debt levels are
you know not going to affect humans but
who knows that the end is one of these
twenty years it might but
it here's my everything too weird
spending all this money to take up the
sweet little fishies and drive the
thing what be nice to use that money to
actually
fixed up the hot the the issue as we've
got back like right
some alternative energy week you know
it's just so that's the part that that
always fascinates me
goldberg dress a so that's the part that
always gets me because the people that
say but we're not doing you know climate
changes in actually happening they seem
to be the people that are more
interested in money
but it seems to me there's also a lot of
money that could be made in going green
and you wouldn't be hurting anyone try
that
the the disconnect that I don't
understand yeah it's always the
yeah but I got this stuff already put in
yeah we got the oil pump that a lot
don't pull
every oil palm bout with saw much I
wanna get
older adult way and when leave tapped or
not when it's this much and I gave up
this much money to start all over again
slowly build and a market as opposed to
rock n roll
Lismore an armored I guarantee you know
these these big oil companies they do
these ten years an REO
things they're they're looking at this
step they they get where they're going
to have to go
because they want customers they wanna
make money in 10 15 20 years
but you're right they wanna you know
squeeze every little bit out before they
that make the big turn so there is this
just the next step in evolution that's
probably been going on for ever and ever
will just get to a point where we
ravaged this planet so much that we just
have to go somewhere else
I mean that sort of what's basic measure
about right we're gonna have to go
somewhere else
and they will probably do it there till
I guess that's what avatar was about i
think is
I believe you just did that yes it was
very good I but
you know while where this version averse
consuming species
we're pretty much this work parasitic
predatory
threat to any place we go we put a flag
and we
photograph ourselves worthy but we're
already immediately killing everything
around us to set up camp you know
yeah another there are other animals
they're already doing it will be there
absolute best at it wherever we go
figure top predator wherever regardless
we show up on mars and then the day we
get there somebody that a little more
advanced than ice also realize that they
needed to get there too and they're gone
they're a little bigger
that all work out well for the humans
that's right we make good pets
back I we will make we will make it
better
really well